hello everyone and welcome to a really
amazing game from yesterday's new inches
classic uh
not finals but uh from the clash for
third place it's lebanon versus shakira
mahmoud and while
magnus and hikaru were battling it out
for first place
to uh it out to see who will clinch
third place and this is uh one of the
games that was played uh there were
a lot of amazing games uh but um i'm
only one person i can only cover
so many and uh well as the other match
was the final so
i decided to cover that one uh mostly
but of course i will uh
show a game from this match as well and
this game i don't know i
went through all of the games and this
one is just uh well pure perfection yeah
so to say
you will see like uh there is nothing
that can be better in this game uh for
it to be more perfect for for the
winning side i'm not saying that anyone
won but
uh you know uh could be that someone has
uh and uh well i just like to hear your
opinion as well because this is uh
it couldn't have been played any better
so without further further ado eleven
with the white pieces uh opens with e4
uh we have uh c5 mamidaro goes for the
sicilian defense we have knight to f3 e6
and now d4 striking in the center we
have c
captures knight captures and knight to
f6 and if you
uh if you've noticed i did some
redecorating i've added some
uh some uh foam uh that should prevent
echo
uh or is it maybe reverb uh so the sound
should be better in this video but if
it's still not okay
i still have some extra foam left so i
can use that as well so do
uh mention maybe if uh if it's an
improvement uh
to the to the previous video because to
me it is but i know most of you guys are
probably using headphones to listen to
this so
i'm i would be very interested in your
opinion as i've never used this stuff so
hopefully hopefully it works
uh so knight to f6 we have knight to c3
and now
knight to c6 uh going for the four
knights variation of the sicilian
uh we have knight captures b capture so
of course black will capture with the b
pawn he wants the strike in the center
and now white prevents this by pushing
e5 the knight is under attack we have
knight to d5
offering a trade of knights and while
white could trade here this is perfectly
fine for black nothing uh you know
yes you do have double pawns but you can
always just push this one and exchange
it for this one and your
your center will be uh well uh perfectly
fine
so instead we have knight to e4 by 11
and now queen to c7 taking care of that
d6 square
as the knight might have some ideas here
uh now the e5 point is under attack so
we have
f4 and now comes rook to b8 makes sense
there's a semi-open b file so why not
use it for the rook
even though the most played move here is
queen to b6 but uh mama dark prepared
something very nice so rook to b8
and now a3 taking away the b4 square
from black's pieces we have queen to b6
now
putting a lot of pressure along the b
file but also just uh
controlling this entire diagonal which
is uh
uh which is a an amazing one and it's
usually the one that black
tends to use uh in in in such uh
position so here we have queen to f3 uh
developing the queen and now there is
one game where uh
queen the a5 check was played but here
we have bishop to e7
and it is already as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
uh how many are uh sorry how eleven
deals with this
uh he pushes c4s and c4 is
uh is a great move as it dislodges the
knight from this uh
uh position here but moving the knight
uh
basically wins the game for white and
it's so crazy i'm just going to show it
to you very quickly
the knight has to go somewhere and you
don't really have any squares other than
for example knight to c7
but then you get knight to d6 check
captures captures the knight has to move
once again
and after let's say knight to a6 you're
gonna play queen to c3
put pressure on g7 and one black once
black takes care of this by either
playing f6 or castles castles that does
appear to be more natural now we play b4
and
incredible as it is this is uh this is
winning for white
the problem is c5 is coming and if you
get this c5 in
then this pawn chain is just unstoppable
it completely destroys the black's
entire position and there is no playing
this
so black would be forced to play
something like c5 and white of course
just pushes b5 here and wins the knight
so that's
basically the idea behind c4 and uh you
know
is there anything mamidarov can do here
to prevent such such a devastating loss
uh of course there is as i've already
mentioned this is a perfect game
so here f5 uh counter attacking with an
attack on this knight so what do you do
here
uh well now you you kind of don't want
to play this
captur because black would just capture
on e4
and after queen captures now we're going
to play e captures on d5 and all of a
sudden
uh black's position is just uh just
excellent you're going to castle king
side here you're going to have a nice
rook on the open f file
the queen cutting off this diagonal
completely the bishop can also join the
party
uh you can't really develop this bishop
because the b2 pawn would be hanging so
it would be terrible to play this with
with white
so instead after this f5 move we don't
have a trade but rather just
knight back to d2 and knight to d2 is
where the perfection starts knight to f2
is
white's last hope here uh knight to d6
also playable but knight to f2 maybe a
better retreat if you
already want to retreat your knight but
knights the d2
simply doesn't work and because the
bishop
no longer guards the e3 square and this
is a huge problem the queen and knight
will now do some serious damage
although it's not uh not right away
clear
uh knights the e3 is played now
threatening knight to c to check which
would of course win the rook on a1
so bishop to d3 not a problem 11 is
thinking i'm just going to move the
knight and then this knight will be just
weirdly placed here but now mamidarov
doesn't play something
like castles and goes for a safe move uh
rather
g5 now and now what do you play here
it's a really really tough position to
be in with white because uh the move
that 11 was
most likely planning something like
knight to f1 uh to kick away this knight
or simply to trade everything off
uh would be would be playable but then
for example just knight captures on f1
rook captures and g captures an f4 and
again it's black
black's the one who's attacking even
queen to h5 check doesn't really do
anything you're just going to move the
king and your king is perfectly safe
here there are so many pawns here you
can put your king on c7
it's not a problem and if something like
rook captures on f4
then we get this queen to g1 check
attacking the pawn if bishop to f1
guarding this
now we're going to play rook captures on
b2 and white's position
is very very much unplayable if bishop
captures then we're just going to
deliver check pick up this rook
and you know just enjoy a better
position if queen e2 for example
captures and
it's a better position for black black
is also up upon so
this is what happens uh if uh white
decides to do something like this so
without the knight to f1 move you really
don't have a
good continuation so here g3 was played
now just adding another defender but now
mamidiarov uh
finds a way how to how to do things
properly g captures on f4 we have g
captures on f4 and now rook the g8 again
the absolute strongest move recommended
by the engine and uh
pretty much i think i think all of the
moves media have played so far
uh were the absolute strongest
recommended by the engine uh so rook the
g8
and now knight to f1 now uh hoping to
get some trades in but now
uh mamidarov doesn't care he just plays
knight the g2 with
check we have king to e2 and now comes
queen to d4 and what do you play here
uh not a lot uh if you if you attack the
queen with something like bishop here
it's really pointless just queen
captures on b2 and other than that you
really don't have a good move
uh 11 played the absolute strongest move
uh
recommended by the engine but even this
is is nowhere near enough to to survive
this attack
because now okay the rook is no longer
guarding the knight you are threatening
to pick it up with the queen
but it's uh it's all over uh so feel
free to pause the video and
win this game for mamidyarov while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this
amazing idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
rook captures on b2 with check and now
there really isn't a good move
if you don't capture this then what what
can you even play there's really not
not much to play if you just move the
king for example king f1
rogue b3 that's uh i mean that's game
there's really no
no playing this you could play something
like king captures on g2 then rook
captures on d3 comes
and uh well uh there's still the rook
there's still the bishop
pair the bishop pair will will be
activated very soon and
it's uh well it's uh simply an
unplayable position the rook on a1 is
hanging i mean it's it's just crazy
so instead after rook captures on b2 11
captured on b2 but now it's pretty much
the same just queen captures on b2 with
check king the f1 and here amazing as it
is uh
here he didn't go for rook captures on
a1 and allow something like king
captures here
he just played knight to h4 and it was
in this position on move 21
uh that uh lebanon resigned the game and
what an amazing
amazing game for shakthi armadyarov who
basically played a perfect game here
i i don't know how much of it was
preparation how much was uh you know
moose found over the board but
regardless this this is a perfect game
with the black pieces
and uh levin uh did not make any
all that uh you know uh uh he didn't
make any serious mistake but
it was at this point when he retreated
to d2 he simply allowed
this knight to come to e3 and it's it's
all
it's it's a very tricky position but uh
allowing this knight to come to e3 was a
deadly mistake
uh so after this uh uh knight stage four
he resigns because now
there's really nothing he can do because
the rook here is hanging
and you don't really have a good way of
defending this because your queen on f3
is hanging as well
and if you try something you could try
rugby one to try and trade pieces off
uh well we're just gonna capture it and
then after bishop captures pick up the
queen
and if you look uh closely uh black is
up a full piece so this is of course
unplayable
and on the other hand if you don't do
something like that you could play queen
d1 maybe try and guard the rook but it's
it doesn't matter just queen g2 check
and we uh the
the rook here on h1 is defended but
after king one knight f3 check and the
king has no squares you would have to
give up the queen and that's it queen
captures an f3 and that's game over
so really really an amazing game uh by
mamidyarov it all it took was one
bad move with the knight and it's often
said that a move with the knight back is
the strongest move but here
it was it was most definitely not okay
if it was knight f2 then yes but not
knight to d2
and uh regarding the result the first
match
between the two of them so all four
games ended with a
decisive result and all four games were
won by the black pieces and
in the second match uh the the second
day uh uh again
uh all of the games that were won were
one with the black pieces so mommy are
off on the second date won
two games with the black pieces one of
them ended in a draw
and this was enough for him to clinch
the match so it was uh in fact chocolate
and mamiyarov who who
who uh won third place in this new chess
classic
uh by defeating uh such such an amazing
player like like lebanon
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really uh and
uh really it's hard to even explain how
how amazing this game is i hope i did uh
you know at least
a little bit of a decent job providing
some
uh intel on it so i hope you guys
enjoyed that uh i would like to thank
ricardo ross uh fair and sombai uh happy
birthday mina
uh simon heath and meadowfan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day
and do comment if the sound is at least
a little bit better than in the previous
video if this foam is even doing
anything
uh see you soon